it's great to welcome back to the
program today jack barski who's a
retired and reformed ex-undercover kgb
agent also author of the great book deep
undercover my secret life entangled
allegiances as a kgb spy in america
which we spoke with him about in some
detail last time and uh which i've read
and can recommend to you jack great to
have you back on today
well uh i'm delighted to be back
so i think one of the things that would
be interesting to get your thoughts on
would be that there is so much
speculation and pontificating on the
sort of psychology of putin and what has
driven this particular invasion of
ukraine at this particular time
everything from illness to a desire to
restore the former ussr to its former
glory to everything in between has been
sort of cited
how are you kind of thinking about the
last few months that have taken place
there militarily
well we would talk about the timing uh
he's an opportunist
he perceives weakness
in the american government and
up until he did the invasion there was
uh
quite a bit of weakness within nato
you know
if you remember that uh
uh there's this controversial uh action
that donald trump took when he went uh
to europe to nato and told them to pay
up already and pay their the share that
they promised because they were all
under paying
and so uh putin has never made a secret
out of his long-term plan
it's just a west that didn't didn't pay
attention to it didn't take it seriously
as
as
particularly the u.s intelligence
services were
focused on
fighting terrorism
and pretty much ignored what's going on
in russia now we had a
reset with russia which was asinine
uh when it didn't work
uh that was under obama and and then you
know and then trump was uh you know
blowing smoke
uh
but but there wasn't really
a recognition that there's there's some
some real chance that this is going to
blow
so and it was i forgot when it was but
sometime
uh in the
in the late
2010s to 2015 or so uh putin actually
openly declared at a conference in
europe where there were heads of state
that
his mission is to
reinstate
a greater russia not the soviet union
uh he he is focused on
on this slavic speaking people that
would
eventually include poland and the czech
republic and uh and a few others but but
he wants you know he's looking at
the russia that peter the great rule
that wasn't a great country either but
you know uh it's
peter the great
is an icon in russian history and and uh
this this is
you know putin wants to be
uh
seen as
the success of peter the great good luck
peter the great was uh six feet seven
tall putin is not
reaching
um so um
uh and then and and most recently two
years ago there was a
uh an essay was published
uh by russian media
it was published by also in english
where he quite and it was was signed
the author is vladimir putin whether he
was the order or not or not it was
signed it was published in his name
where he clearly
restated his long-term goal
and so when he invaded crimea
uh that was um
five years ago i believe and and the
west didn't didn't even
you know
sneeze
there was nothing going on he said well
now is the time to to go into ukraine
and expand our reach and that's that's
pretty much my my view on things
one of the um
things that has surprised some is that
it appears as though
russia may have misjudged the degree and
the scope of ukrainian resistance and
what seems
may be surprising about that
is that russia is known for a quite
extensive
intelligence service kgb which you're
very much familiar with other
departments as well
what how could something that from the
outside random people were saying you
know there might be more resistance than
is assumed how how could such an
extensive intelligence apparatus
misjudge that if they did
okay first of all uh the entire world uh
misjudged uh the the will of the
ukrainians to fight okay because
nobody's really paying attention
nobody's paying attention to history uh
that there has been a
uh
intrinsic hatred of of russia everything
russian coming out of ukraine
and uh one of one of the worst things
that
actually
uh
is is still sticking in ukrainian's mind
the history where stalin
went into ukraine in in the early 30s
and and and confiscated all the grain
and over four million ukrainians starved
uh
to death
and that is in the part of the world
that is the most fertile
period uh this this was because the
stalin wanted to force collectivization
so and so and and there's one thing
you got you got to understand is
if you invade a country
where
everybody is a soldier not just the men
but the women and the children you will
not in the long run win that war we
found it out in vietnam
we found it out in afghanistan
okay
so uh but with regard to intelligence
services that's a that's a very
interesting subject
i
i guarantee you there are undercover
agents
of the ukraine in russia and vice versa
there's a lot of misleading going on
they can because they uh
ukrainians are bilingual almost all of
them and russians have no problem uh
learning
to speak ukrainian uh because it's just
very very similar so you get you get
intelligence you don't know if it's real
or it's from a double agent
and it goes both ways
uh and and and the other thing is
assuming that putin got some decent
intelligence
uh
maybe his his intelligence opera
apparatus the gru primarily
had the right information
did you see that tape
where uh
putin
is is just treating the head of the svr
the another intelligence service like a
fourth grader yes
that guy was shaking in his boots so
you know you may not want to give the
boss bad news
and and if you have the courage to do so
the boss may just say you know you're
full of
sorry
so so it's a it's a very fluid situation
there um
and and if if the russians didn't have
the right intelligence
you know you can't blame the cia either
right you know one of the um things that
i gathered from reading your book
uh and reading about
other
sometimes double agents former kgb etc
that there seems to be a certain level
of paranoia
within uh the apparatus that includes if
i recall correctly an entire department
that just
observes and verifies that kgb agents
are not working for some other
intelligence service with that level
of paranoia
what can you deduce about the images for
example of putin sitting
40 feet away from advisors at a table
and and to talk a little bit about like
the psychology of what happens behind
the scenes
uh the the the paranoia is uh
is
inherited
you know that uh
during the reign of stalin
there were periodic purges
within the military within the
intelligence services because stalin was
the ultimate uh paranoid individual
and uh and and so
this just became part of the dna of of
uh
the russian army and the and the
and the intelligence services
because
you know
when the soviet union fell apart and the
kgb was uh
dissolved and became
three different intelligence services
um
who
trained the new guys who trained the
ones that are now in charge is that
it's the old kgb and they had paranoia
in their blood
and and in in general the
uh the the
the russian dna period
has
a paranoid gene and that's justified uh
the russian state was formed in the
middle ages and ever since it
came into being it was always invaded
from the north the vikings came in from
the east to mongrel from the west it was
napoleon and from the south it was the
turks
so they were constantly under siege
and uh so and that by the way that is uh
a
platform that
or you know a history that putin is
using
to
uh tell his people that whatever
is wrong with russia is all
it's the west fault it's the fault of
nato it's the fault of the united states
and uh the the united states and nato
can't wait
to just conquer russia and and
and and you know kill the russian spirit
and and destroy the russian nation and
they they have bought it
they actually have bought it
and if you know people have ruminated in
public you know what what would it take
to get rid of vladimir putin you don't
even want to try because you think you
get rid of putin that russia will change
the the russian nation
is severely contaminated
and and decontamination
is a hard thing to do the the allied
founded out
uh when when they tried to
get the nazi ideology out of every
german brain after world war ii it took
forever and was not in every case
successful that's interesting because
while certainly what you say is true
it also seems as though even
within some of putin's top generals
they're not necessarily thrilled about
this incursion into ukraine and to some
degree it does feel to me that if putin
was killed or died
there would not be the same interest in
continuing this that there is from putin
you you think that it would not change
well you're talking about the generals
you know
and this is speculative but uh it seems
to make sense the the russian army has
uh had a lot of losses that weren't
anticipated and so if you're a general
and and you
you're uh
you're involved in that invasion
uh you can see that
the russian army is being weakened to
some degree okay
uh
but
don't
the
there are enough hawks
in the putin uh regime underneath putin
to continue
what he started and the russian people
will will not get out in the streets and
demonstrate and
stop this war they will not because they
know it's necessary you understand also
uh the the whole um
the whole
canard that
russia is fighting nazis
it's partially true
in what sense
yes sir
uh and i i give you
just one item one fact that uh
you never heard in in the mainstream
media you know who stefan bandera was no
stefan bandera was a ukrainian nazi he
had a
he was uh
he led a nazi type movement and when
hitler came he joined hitler uh
with his troops and there were a lot of
ukrainian uh
guards in concentration camps and peop
ukrainians who participate
participated in uh
in
killing jews okay that's a historic fact
so now here comes the interesting uh
afterthought
two years ago
it was on bandera's 100th birthday
the ukrainian government
issued commemorative stamps to honor him
now there has to be some nazis right and
even up in the government now uh
is not a nazi for sure and i don't i
don't believe the country is is a nazi
country but but you see if you if you uh
want to sell a big lie
if you have a kernel of truth it's so
much easier to assume
uh jack how do you see this war
concluding because there's the idea that
it will only conclude either when putin
is given an exit that allows him to save
face or he dies
uh it will not stop when he dies uh i'm
convinced this will go on
for a long time it's a war of attrition
so far zielinski has
indicated that he is not going to give
an acre of land
so until
unless he is is willing to say okay i'm
going to let go of donbass uh because
there's too too many ukrainians dying
uh but um
i uh i have a a a friend who who hails
from that region and he was in an
intelligence in russia and he he knows
he has a really good understanding of
what drives ukrainians they are fighting
not for land they're fighting for their
uh freedom
and for their uh their existence as a
nation
and as long as
that is as long as they're willing to
fight
to the death
that that whole war is going to go on
for a long time god forbid even if
russia takes all of ukraine and occupies
it you know what you're going to have a
guerrilla war like in vietnam and
in afghanistan so
there's no at this point there's no end
inside you you so the idea that in three
months
as a result of negotiations this could
essentially come to an end you don't
think there's even a chance of that
they're not talking at all right
but i mean even you just don't even
think that that's a plausible scenario
period
not not not in the near future not not
in the next several months uh the the uh
situation
in the field would have to change
dramatically to
go one way or the other
is there some level of death and
destruction for the russian forces that
would get putin to say we have to cut
our losses and retreat or is that not in
his dna
i
he's on a one-way street okay and
he he will
he will pulverize the entire country if
he can and has to
well
uh we've been speaking with jack barsky
we're uh linking to his book uh retired
and reformed ex-undercover kgb agent uh
jack always great speaking with you
appreciate your time yeah may i may i
just add the the fact that there's also
a
a podcast out there it's called the
agent it's an audio documentary it's
very well done and if you don't want to
read the whole book
the story
is in that podcast and it's uh it's also
told not just by me but by a lot of
people who were important in my life
that's a big i recommend the book but
the podcast sounds like it's a way to
get a lot a lot of the same story as
well thanks jack appreciate it thank you
bye-bye